.
Ando findet in Armenien
sein Elternhaus,
in dem er bis zu seiner Flucht lebte.
Wow, das ist ja winzig.
Aber das ist meine Herkunft.
In den USA freut sich Susan
auf ein besonderes Treffen.
Nach 21 Jahren soll sie
ihren Vater wiedersehen.
Ich sehe jemanden.
Aber der ist nicht gross genug.
Das ist eine Reise
zurück zu den Wurzeln,
eine Reise in "Meine fremde Heimat".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ando flüchtete mit sieben Jahren
mit seiner Familie aus Armenien.
23 Jahre später ist er zum ersten Mal
wieder in seiner Heimat,
gemeinsam mit seiner Freundin Giada.
* Orientalische Musik *
Andos Mutter und seine zwei Brüder
wohnen in der Schweiz.
Weil es immer wieder Streit gab,
hat er keinen Kontakt mehr.
Sein Vater starb vor vier Jahren
und ist in Armenien begraben.
* Gespräch auf Armenisch *
In der fremden Heimat
warten viele Verwandte auf Ando.
Heute besucht er seine Tante, die
Schwester seines verstorbenen Vaters.
Sie hat Töchter
und inzwischen auch Enkelkinder.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr gesehen,
seit ich Armenien verlassen habe.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich sie noch ...
... in Erinnerung.
- ... richtig in Erinnerung habe.
(Tante) Bari galust!
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich war in ihrem Alter,
als ich wegging.
Auf der Flucht konnte Andos Familie
nur das Nötigste mitnehmen.
Deshalb hat er keine Fotos
von sich als kleiner Junge.
Sie sagt, sie habe alte Bilder
von mir, als ich klein war,
und ob ich Bilder mitbringen könne.
Das ist mein Onkel,
der Bruder meines Vaters.
Ich sehe diese Bilder
zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben.
Ein schönes Bild.
Ich habe leider keine Bilder.
Ich habe nur eins in Erinnerung.
Es ist kein Bild von mir,
aber von meinem Onkel.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Bilder.
Diese sehe ich zum ersten Mal.
Ich kann ehrlich sagen,
jetzt kommen alte Erinnerungen hoch.
Das ist mein Vater,
das ist meine Mutter.
Das bin ich, das ist mein Gross-
vater, der leider verstorben ist.
Das ist mein älterer Bruder
und das ist meine Cousine.
Ja, ein schönes Bild.
Ja, es ist etwas Besonderes. Ich
habe sie noch nie vereint gesehen.
Ich ...
... habe Ando
immer nur allein gekannt.
Ando hat auf dieser Reise
nicht nur viele Erinnerungen
an seine Kindheit gefunden,
sondern auch die Familie,
die er zu Hause nicht mehr hat.
Die Familie endlich wieder sehen -
das ist einer Gründe,
weshalb Susan unterwegs ist.
Sie wuchs in der Schweiz auf,
ihr Vater lebte in den USA.
Mit Mitte 20 ging Susan
für vier Jahre nach Kalifornien,
deshalb ist San Francisco
die erste Station
auf ihrer Reise in die fremde Heimat.
Hier leben Freunde, die sie
seit 20 Jahren nicht gesehen hat.
Einer davon ist Vernon.
Vernon ist wirklich
ein herzensguter Mensch.
Und ich ...
Ich werde ihn gleich sehen,
und ich habe das Gefühl,
dass er im Kern noch derselbe ist.
Ein sehr spiritueller Mensch auch.
Einfach ein lieber Kerl.
Monika
ist eine gute Freundin von Susan
und ihre Reisebegleiterin.
Ich lerne hier
Susans Geschichte kennen.
Denn vorher habe ich sie ...
... habe ich ihre ganzen
Amerikaabenteuer nicht gekannt.
Susan führte in ihrer Zeit
in Kalifornien ein Hippieleben,
wollte sich
als Künstlerin durchschlagen
und verdiente ihr Geld
mit unterschiedlichen Jobs.
In den letzten 20 Jahren
hat sie den Kontakt
zu den meisten Freunden verloren.
Bis gestern, als sie
Vernons Telefonnummer bekam.
* Entspannte Musik *
Eine schöne Gegend.
- Und so ruhig.
Total.
Meinst du, das ist es?
Autsch!
- Fall nicht hin!
* Susan lacht. *
I directed you right.
I love you.
- I love you too.
Wow!
So nice to see you
after all this time.
So, this is the kitchen.
Hello, kitchen.
Dass Susan einfach so auftaucht,
nach 20 Jahren und von weit entfernt,
überrascht Vernon nicht.
Die Planeten
haben es ihm bereits verraten.
Er hat sich nicht stark verändert.
I'm still going to school.
Toll. Er hat sich
überhaupt nicht verändert.
Same smile.
Für mich ist es wunderschön.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl,
wenn ich an Menschen denke,
also Freunde,
die wirklich mein Herz berühren,
dass sie vielleicht
zur gleichen Zeit an mich denken.
Was er gesagt hat, bestätigt das.
Wirklich ... es passt einfach genau.
Ta-da!
So schön.
Susan ist noch keine 24 Std. im Land
und hat bereits
zwei alte Freunde gefunden.
Ich bin gerade mega geflasht.
Wie die Zeit ...
Zeit bedeutet einfach nichts.
Dieser Moment ist ...
Ein bisschen Silber in den Haaren,
aber sonst noch alles gleich.
Keine Fremdheit, nichts.
Am Ende dieser Reise will sie für das
Treffen mit ihrem Vater bereit sein,
nach über 20 Jahren.
Aber vorher will sie unbedingt
noch einen Freund überraschen.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Bei Ando und Giada gibt es
einen weiteren Familienbesuch.
Seine Cousine begleitet ihn zu
seiner Grossmutter mütterlicherseits.
Bei ihr
verbrachte Ando früher viel Zeit.
* Sie sprechen armenisch. *
Hier wohnt sie. Und wir sind ...
- Wo genau?
Wir müssen hier rein.
Ich gehe vor, in Ordnung?
- Ja.
Seine Grossmutter sah ihn zuletzt
als siebenjährigen Jungen.
Ich hoffe, ich bin hier richtig.
- Wohnt sie gleich hier?
Bist du sicher?
Hat sie gesagt, es sei hier?
Ja, Marlene tatik?
Komm!
* Sie sprechen armenisch. *
* Lachen *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Schluchzen *
Okay?
Sie ist so ein gutherziger Mensch.
Ich freue mich so.
Schau mal, ein Bild von mir!
- So süss, oh mein Gott!
Schau mal, was für ein grosses Bild
sie von mir hat.
Nur von dir, wie?
- Ja.
Aber das bist nicht du?
- Das ist mein Onkel.
Mit seinem Sohn.
Ich werde ...
Ich bin sehr gerührt,
dass sie so ...
(Mit erstickter Stimme)
Wirklich, ich bin ...
Es macht mich extrem stolz, dass
sie so grosse Bilder von mir hat.
Sie hat ja Kinder und andere Enkel,
aber dass sie ...
Man sieht, von niemandem sonst
hat sie so ein grosses Bild.
Das zeigt mir,
wie sehr sie mich vermisst hat.
* Sie sprechen armenisch. *
Sie sagt, ich müsse dich küssen,
du seist so herzig.
Die Grossmutter
erzählt von Andos Vater,
der für sie mehr gewesen sei
als nur ein Schwiegersohn.
Er ging nach ein paar Jahren
in der Schweiz zurück nach Armenien
und habe sie täglich besucht,
bis zu seinem Tod vor vier Jahren.
Also ...
Das tut weh.
Zu hören, dass mein Vater kein Glück
im Leben hatte, tut mir weh.
Das ist ...
Andos Vater ist ausserhalb der Stadt
in Dzoraglukh begraben.
Aber bevor Ando dorthin geht,
will er noch sein Elternhaus suchen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Barev.
Abschied in Armenien,
Wiedersehensfreude in den USA.
Susan ist tief
in ihre Vergangenheit eingetaucht.
Heute geht es weiter.
Gemeinsam mit ihrer Freundin Monika
fährt sie aus der Stadt hinaus
zu Darriel.
Auch er war vor 20 Jahren
ein wichtiger Mann in Susans Leben.
Wir fahren jetzt nach Sonoma
und schauen, ob Darriel ...
Mit ihm und einigen anderen
habe ich mich
um einen alten Künstler gekümmert.
Ich will schauen,
ob er wirklich noch an der Adresse,
die ich recherchiert habe, wohnt.
Darriel pflegte damals
einen betagten Künstler
und Susan half ihm dabei.
Eigentlich
wollte sie etwas anderes tun.
Ich wollte damit ausprobieren,
wie ich mich als Künstlerin
durchschlagen kann.
In der Praxis zeigte sich dann,
dass es fast am besten geht,
wenn man es
mit anderen Jobs kombiniert.
Und es hat sich gezeigt,
dass mir Pflegearbeit zusagt.
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Auch dieser Besuch
ist eine Überraschung.
Darriel hat keine Ahnung,
dass Susan auf dem Weg zu ihm ist.
Ich glaube fast, das ist es.
Hier ist es.
Ich stelle den mal hierhin.
Das wird wohl nicht gleich geklaut.
(Lisa) Nice to meet you. Welcome.
Darriel ist im Stress,
er muss ins Radiostudio.
Oh, cool.
(Darriel) I'll see you there.
Okay!
Als Überrascherin
werde ich jetzt überrascht.
Wir gehen jetzt auf den Airstream,
also in seine Radioshow.
Einmal pro Woche moderiert Darriel
seine eigene Radiosendung.
Das wollen sich Susan und Monika
nicht entgehen lassen.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Sorry for the wrong address. My bad!
Ah, okay. No problem!
- We found you.
I'm on air right now.
I left all the doors open.
* Lachen *
Darriel spielt v.a. Platten
aus den guten alten Zeiten.
... the address was wrong.
Come on in!
So cool! The door's open.
Susan fühlt sich sofort wie zu Hause.
* Rockmusik *
There we go.
Here we go,
there's our dance party.
And just like the old days.
Have a seat.
- Oh!
This is okay.
I need to adjust this a little.
Jetzt hat sich auch Darriel
vom ersten Schock erholt.
* Lachen *
Zwischen den Songs schwärmen
die beiden von den alten Zeiten,
als sie sich
um einen betagten Künstler kümmerten.
Ted hiess er.
It's not just all about you.
- Again!
Ja, es war mehr als ein Job.
Eine Herzenssache.
Er war zwar ihr Arbeitgeber,
aber offenbar war es wirklich
ein freundschaftliches Verhältnis.
Und es ging nicht nur um die Pflege,
sondern, wie er sagte,
auch um die intellektuelle
Unterhaltung,
um intellektuelle Anreize.
Ja, wir haben ihm
Gedichte vorgelesen,
die er hören wollte.
Wir spielten für ihn
Bach-Schallplatten.
Ja.
Nein!
Smooth!
Dieses Lied
spielt Darriel nur für Ted.
Als Dankeschön, dass er durch ihn
Susan kennengelernt hat.
* "The Waiting" von
Tom Petty and the Heartbreakers *
# Baby, we know better
than to try and pretend.
# Honey, no one
could have ever told me about this.
# I said ...
- # ... yeah, yeah.
# Yeah, yeah.
- # Yeah, yeah.
# The waiting is the hardest part.
# Every day you see one more card.
# You take it on faith,
you take it to the heart.
# The waiting is the hardest part.
Die ersten sieben Jahre
lebte Ando in Armenien,
gemeinsam mit seinen Eltern
und den zwei Brüdern.
Er ist auf der Suche
nach seinem Elternhaus.
Es ist umgeben von Hochhäusern,
also von solchen Wohnblocks.
Und es ist klein
und hat einen Vorgarten.
Schwierig.
Nein, wir müssen uns nur umschauen.
Huch! Mein Gott!
Mein Gefühl sagt mir,
ich müsse dort schauen.
Merci.
Nein!
Ich sagte doch, mein Gefühl ...
- Oh mein Gott!
Hier.
- Krass.
Er sagte zu mir, das sei nicht hier.
Ich sagte:
"Warte, ich will mal schauen."
Ich sagte, es sehe genau so aus.
Wow.
Boah.
Wow!
Hier hat mein Vater etwas gemacht.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Das ist unser ...
Hier bin ich aufgewachsen.
Das ist ja winzig.
Wir waren hier zu fünft.
Es gab hier nichts,
wir hatten wirklich nichts.
Man sieht, hier war nichts.
Das ist meine Herkunft.
(Unter Tränen) In der Schweiz
habe ich nie vergessen,
woher ich gekommen bin -
deshalb habe ich mich durchgebissen.
Das hat mir die Kraft gegeben.
Das hat mich so hart gemacht.
Wir haben es in der Schweiz
so schön.
Immer wenn es mir schlecht ging,
dachte ich:
"In Armenien hatte ich nichts."
Das habe ich nie vergessen.
Ich bin dankbar, dass ich in
der Schweiz so viel aufbauen konnte.
Das war meine Motivation:
Ich hatte nichts.
Man sieht es.
Das ist ...
Seit dem Tod seines Vaters vor
vier Jahren wohnt hier niemand mehr.
Das Haus will, dass ich hierbleibe.
Aha.
Wahnsinn, alles verrostet.
(Seufzend) Gehen wir.
* Melancholische Musik *
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik *
In Kalifornien läuft alles nach Plan.
Susan hat alte Freunde getroffen
und fühlt sich wieder wie zu Hause.
Morgen fliegt sie mit Monika
an die Ostküste nach Rochester.
Dort leben ihr Vater
und ihre zwei Halbschwestern.
Vor diesem Wiedersehen
nach über 20 Jahren
braucht sie
eine kleine Auszeit am Strand.
Wow!
- Es ist hier ziemlich gefährlich.
Ja, einfach mal, um so einen Moment
in der Zeit zu haben,
um wieder runterzufahren,
zu meditieren,
so zu atmen wie es mir ...
Ein ... aus.
Ja, auch als Vorbereitung
für den grossen Trip
übers Land und dann zu Dad.
* Wellenrauschen *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Kalifornien ist abgehakt.
Susan und Monika
fliegen einmal quer über die USA
nach Rochester
im Bundesstaat New York.
Ich bin wirklich
in freudiger Erwartung darauf,
jetzt dann bei Dad anzukommen,
meine Schwestern zu treffen.
Jetzt habe ich wieder Platz,
und ...
Irgendwie ...
Ja, vorher war ich so erfüllt
von den Eindrücken.
Auch jetzt noch, aber jetzt kann ich
ins Auge fassen, was noch kommt.
Mein persönlicher Hauptact
dieser Reise.
Mein Dad.
Und meine Schwestern.
* Sanfte Musik *
Während Susan das grosse Treffen
mit ihrem Vater bevorsteht,
ist Andos Reise schon bald zu Ende.
Bevor er am letzten Tag
aufs Land fährt,
gibt es bei seinem Onkel in Jerewan
Khorovats.
Das bedeutet Gegrilltes.
Ein Menü, das nur bei besonderen
Anlässen aufgetischt wird.
Für Ando und Giadas Abschied hat sich
die ganze Familie versammelt.
* Fröhliche armenische Musik *
So gut.
- Das ist armenisches Khorovats.
Schaschlik.
Nein, in der Schweiz darf man so
etwas nicht auf dem Balkon machen.
Dafür brauchst du
eine Sonderbewilligung.
Aber in Armenien
ist das etwas einfacher.
Man darf grillieren, wann man will,
egal welche Uhrzeit.
2 Uhr morgens ist kein Problem.
Man wird keine Reklamationen
aus der Nachbarschaft hören.
Das sieht wirklich mega aus.
Als hätte ich Geburtstag.
Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn.
Auch in Italien wird viel gekocht,
wenn Gäste kommen.
Es ist viel! Es gibt nichts,
was es nicht gibt auf dem Tisch.
* Fröhliche armenische Musik *
* Die Cousine spricht. *
Sie sagt, beim nächsten Mal
müsse ich verheiratet kommen.
Es ist Sonntag. Ando und Giada
wollen einen Gottesdienst besuchen,
gemeinsam mit dem Onkel
und seinem Sohn.
Armenien war im 4. Jh.
das erste Land,
das das Christentum
als Staatsreligion anerkannte.
Sie fahren ins Johanneskloster, das
hoch über der Kassagh-Schlucht steht.
Immer wenn ich
einen Wettkampf hatte,
ging ich in Baden
in die katholische Kirche.
Für mich allein.
Aber in letzter Zeit bete ich
allein, nicht mehr in der Kirche.
* Glockengeläut *
* Kirchlicher Gesang *
Mit so viel Schutz von oben ist Ando
bereit für sein allerletztes Ziel,
das Grab seines Vaters.
Susan ist in Rochester angekommen.
In dieser Stadt
wurde sie vor 45 Jahren geboren.
Als sie eineinhalb Jahre alt war,
trennten sich ihre Eltern
und ihre Mutter ging mit ihr
in die Schweiz zurück.
Zu ihrem Vater
hatte Susan nur selten Kontakt.
Das letzte Mal
haben sie sich vor 21 Jahren gesehen.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Jetzt ist es endlich so weit.
In 1 Std.
soll sie ihren Vater treffen.
Ich verspüre schon auch
ein bisschen Nervosität.
Ich will ja gut aussehen,
wenn ich Dad treffe.
Logisch.
Ich habe Dad
21 Jahre lang nicht mehr gesehen.
Ja.
Genau, und es ist schon ...
Ich will ja sozusagen einen
guten ersten Eindruck hinterlassen.
Gut.
Ich glaube,
es hat mich stark geprägt ...
... ohne eine Vaterfigur, die ...
Es hat mich geprägt,
ohne ihn aufzuwachsen.
Ja, ein kleiner Mangel an ...
... sozusagen
einer gefestigten Identität
und auch Autorität natürlich.
Genau, und auch dieses Gefühl, dass
man sich immer selbst kümmern muss.
Ich fiebere total mit,
wie diese Begegnung
am Ende ausfallen wird.
Mir wird gerade ganz warm.
Die ersten Nervositätshitzeschübe.
So, ich will es nicht übertreiben.
Sieht gut aus.
- Ja? Danke.
* Sie lacht. *
Den Schlüssel habe ich.
Gut.
Susan ist mit ihrem Vater
auf einer Fussgängerbrücke
in der Stadt verabredet.
* Sanft-beschwingte Musik *
Er meinte sicher diese Brücke.
Ich hoffe es. Er kennt sich ja aus.
Ja, sie waren sicher ab und zu hier,
um Sightseeing zu machen.
Oder auf einem Ausflug.
- Ich sehe jemanden.
Aber der ist nicht gross genug.
Schön hier.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch ein Dad.
Where's Dad?
Auf einer Skala von 1-10
für Nervosität bin ich bei 11.
Tüdüdüdüdüdüdüdüdü!
Ping!
Soll ich ihn anrufen?
Ich weiss nicht, was ich tun soll.
Ruf doch an.
- Aber warum ruft er nicht an?
Jetzt kommen all diese Ängste hoch:
Lässt er mich hier auflaufen?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich es noch lange aushalte.
Oder ob ich da runter soll.
- Ach was!
Ich rufe ihn jetzt an
und sage ihm, wo wir sind.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Dad.
You?
Hey, nein, ich könnte
wirklich vor Angst pinkeln.
Die Nieren sind ja ...
Die Blase
ist von den Organen her ...
Weisst du, die Leber mit Wut,
Nieren und Blase mit Angst.
Und es ist wirklich brutal,
wie es sich gerade auswirkt.
Uh!
Ich kann dir nachfühlen.
* Unruhige Klänge *
Ehrlich, hey!
Komm, wir gehen einfach wieder.
Fuck him!
Meinst du? Ruf doch noch mal an!
Warum?
Um zu sehen, wo er gestrandet ist.
Vielleicht findet er uns nicht.
Aber sorry, wirklich!
Ich habe auch genug davon,
mir für ihn
irgendwelche Entschuldigungen
oder Ausreden zusammenzureimen,
nur damit es nicht so scheisse ist.
He's not here!
We've been waiting for half an hour.
Und wir haben uns beeilt,
um ihn nicht warten zu lassen.
* Düstere Musik *
Nächste Woche
bei "Meine fremde Heimat":
Ando besucht am letzten Tag
der Reise das Grab seines Vaters.
Die schwierigsten Momente sind
die Geschichten über meinen Vater.
Dass er traurig gestorben sei.
Dass er die Hoffnung aufgegeben
hatte, uns wiederzusehen.
Es tut mir immer noch weh,
denn er hat es nicht verdient,
so zu sterben.
Und Susan
verliert langsam die Geduld.
Ich drehe gleich durch und
werfe die Scheisskamera ins Wasser.
Hau ab, Mann!
Ehrlich!
Hi, Dad. Is that you there coming?
Okay, all right.
Taucht Susans Vater noch auf?
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2020